houston gets it back but again russell
westbrook should think
this is not going to happen and he
drills the three
and he's talking to anyone that wants to
listen
[Music]
here comes westbrook again
another explosive transition dunk by
russell westbrook
right into your living room covington's
so good at that
one of the top steels man and westbrook
on the live from hardin
james harden finding his running buddy
russell westbrook on the line hard tries
to knife through blazers do a fantastic
job but not fouling mello to the floor
gary dredd jr tries to fight for the
pork chop no luck at
westbrook and the blazers go straight up
man on that one but then on the scramble
about all five rockets quick enough to
get by everybody though isn't it yeah
first bucket of the game
oh russell oh russell
westbrook
hardin blows by tatum and kicks it out
tucker
first oh ruthless live
legs this late in the game just keep an
eye out you come right into your picture
how about that
good hustle house is able to keep the
ball alive
westbrook to the basket
within five points once trailing by
20. just one score in his first 10
possessions ariza rejected by westbrook
what a recovery by russell westbrook
tries to get that one up going off the
right leg
houston gets it back but again russell
westbrook should think
this is not going to happen and he
drills the three
and he's talking to anyone that wants to
listen
squaring up on one of the best defenders
in the nba
butter
[Applause]
russell westbrook to the basketball
one second left to play russell
westbrook
with his biggest basket
[Music]
russell westbrook a spectacular joke and
it's a two-point game what up it's your
boy adam lefkow did you like that
content
i know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from bleacher